ich glaube nicht dass ihm vorbei und
richtig besten ist das überhaupt nicht
dem herrscher nicht und zeigt dass gott
zu bewegen
kommunales wertiger oder gegen die
erinnere da zeigen wir machen aber auch
unterstütze seine chance da ist sie ganz
klar im land von dschinghis khan wittert
daniel man sei das große geschäft doch
was genau sucht ein appenzeller bei den
mongolen und wie kommt man sehr darauf
dass diese unterschiedlichen kulturen
aufeinander gewartet haben
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
dies kann airport in ulaanbaatar daniel
man sie hat sich längst daran gewöhnt
dass seine ideen bei manchen ein
stirnrunzeln verursachen bereits ein
erster termin kurz nach der landung in
der mongolei ist ein außergewöhnlicher
vor vier jahren überlegte sich manser wo
auf gottes erden es sich lohnen könnte
geld zu investieren
eher zufällig kam er erstmals in die
mongolei in ein land von dem er nur
wusste dass es reich ist an kupfer gold
und kohle und 40 mal so groß wie die
schweiz aber nur von halt so vielen
menschen bewohnt nach jahrhunderten im
würgegriff der nachbarn china und
russland ist die mongolei ein
wirtschaftliches brachland
[Musik]
für polen ist das volumen von such
partner leisten
der freiheitsheld sie sowohl kommunisten
am machtlosen der verzicht genau
ausgesucht parkplatz heißen und jetzt
eins der wohnung ist kaum platz als
anzeichen sehen mit der vergangenheit
mit kommunistischer vergangenheit
wirklich liberalen als schweizer
was gibt es besseres um den kapitalismus
zu frönen
schnell fand man sie in ulan bator
gleichgesinnte zusammen schufen sie ein
firmenkonstrukt zu dem unter anderem
eine bank eine farm und eine beton
fabrik gehören college denn ab montag
sind die kollegen überlegt jetzt auf
1000 dreht bestockt ruft machen ohne im
august wieder nach oben gedreht
schulbetriebs er wieder spielt also
unglaublich denkt die schweizer
maschinenmarkt bewilligung integration
ja dort wirklich schnell mit der beton
firma will man sie heute an die
mongolische börse gehen
doch schon bei der begrüßung seiner
mitarbeiterin kommt die hiobsbotschaft
das geld der schweizer investoren ist
auf dem weg von zürich in die mongolei
stecken geblieben
ok rund 650.000 frankreich sind es die
fehlen
ohne geld kein börsengang doch man sah
lässt sich wenig anmerken und schon gar
nicht unterkriegen
noch während einer kurzen
lagebesprechung mit seinen partnern
beschließt er einen termin vorzuziehen
der ihm am herzen liegt
sinnbild für den wandel des landes sind
die hunderttausenden nomaden die in
jüngster zeit am stadtrand der
hauptstadt sesshaft geworden sind
angezogen von der hoffnung auf ein
besseres leben wovon schweizer
vereinsgründer tores von gut zehn jahre
ja es ist natürlich auf spenden
angewiesen also noch genug da dass wir
haben diesen erstaunlich spenderherz
lieber in der weise dass man teile auf
hof oder gewinn macht ja so ein projekt
so verwirrt ich stellt das ein land aber
das hat druck 60 straßenkinder erhalten
hier in der kinderhilfe bayers galant
die möglichkeit eine schule zu besuchen
[Musik]
die geschäftsführerin sei er auch kino
hat wie viele ihrer kolleginnen zu
kommunistischen zeiten in der ehemaligen
ddr studiert ihr perfektes deutsch kommt
dem schweizer projekt zugute
[Musik]
und heizen tut dann wie im winter micro
mitglieder mit kohle und wo heißt die
dann also wie ihr habt ihr da hinten die
jurten sind weitgehend aus dem stadtbild
verschwunden die meisten leute leben
heute in einfachen häuschen eine
kanalisation und fließend wasser fielen
immer noch die stadtregierung hofft
diese situation mit hilfe ausländischer
investoren zu ändern
mit bestimmten distanz gibt es jeweils
staatlicher brunnen einwohner von diesen
ort wasser gekauft
es sind diese entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
die mensa vor augen hat wenn er von
einer blühenden zukunft des landes
spricht hier gehe etwas in den nächsten
jahren ist er überzeugt
doch wer ist dieser mann den man wegen
seiner geringen körpergröße leicht
unterschätzen könnte
der 42 jährige appenzeller lebt mit
seiner familie im kanton luzern
aufgewachsen ist er auf einem bauernhof
in der ostschweiz
dort lernte er früh dass fleißig sein
muss wer weiterkommen will
nach seiner banken lehre suchte und fand
er im finanzsektor immer neue aufgaben
unter anderem ist er heute chefredakteur
des anlageberater magazins playoffs als
solcher versucht er neue trends
vorauszusehen nicht als einziger hat er
die entwicklung in der mongolei erkannt
mit dem ende der sowjetunion kam die
demokratie und im schlepptau des freien
marktes kamen die goldgräber alles
andere so dass man mit einer schule und
berührt gesteckt und das saarland
enthält vertrauen und unabhängigen also
wie sie passiert wenn man obwohl ich
spiele da wenn wir uns als finanzmanager
pauschale druck war starb sich die
chance sich zweierlei ist ist sich einer
sich die investment zu den tieren weil
wir sonst rentiert das sind funktioniert
denn auch einer der türme zwangsläufig
widerruf muss aber auf höhere für der
mongol für die mongolische bestimmen
also man muss auch sehen muss was ihm im
vorwärts froh wenn wir haben miteinander
ehrlich langfristig entwickeln und ein
monopol ist alles so dass ein kind und
drei jahre verliehen und da gott sein
ach darum das ist das eigentlich alle
können und alle zahlen besser und man
kann menschen für seine ideen begeistern
vor allem wenn er selber fest daran
glaubt zwar könne man in der schweiz
einfach erreicht werden
doch dass er hier auf etwas ganz großes
oft kann er nicht ganz verheimlichen
nicht zufällig steht vor seinem
firmensitz die erste led anzeige des
landes mit den aktuellen börsendaten
bevor es erst nach oben kuranyi
verschiedene broker europäische
unternehmer geschrieben
per mail und vom einteilen den schweizer
deutschland überrascht und erfreut
zugleich
und 26 brooklyn trägerschaft und und
wird den neu rasit leitung von franz
finanzbereich standard übernommen
richard kobayashi hat japanische und
schweizer wurzeln
aufgewachsen ist er in rorschach seit
ein paar jahren lebte er mit seinem
mongolischen frau in ulaanbaatar sie
unter froh dass ich als ich hoffe sie
dann ihr mann sie möchte wissen ob es
neuigkeiten zum verschollenen investoren
geld gibt inzwischen heißt es das geld
sei statt bei der mongolischen
staatsbank in new york gelandet
kurzerhand beschließen mansa und
kobayashi
zusammen mit ihrem einheimischen partner
gold klausuren der staatsbank einen
besuch abzustatten
sie sind überzeugt alles richtig
vorbereitet zu haben und trotzdem hat
die transaktion bisher nicht geklappt
das problem muss bei der bank liegen
gewicht
der unangemeldete besuch bei der
wichtigsten bank des landes erweist sich
aus das richtige vorgehen denn sofort
nehmen sich eine handvoll
bankangestellter des problems an und
tatsächlich nach wenigen minuten klärt
sich die lage und den sklaven als mensa
und seine kollegen anschließend weiter
wollen versperrt nicht eine liane den
weg sondern ein falsch parkierte auto da
hilft keine machete
da braucht's mongolische gelassenheit
was macht sie ihm leibe gerückt
ja auch relativ viel geduld aber man
verrückt nachttisch ungerechtigkeit
finde ich selbst
[Musik]
und was mache ich wenn sein zu erklären
was ist passiert der mongolei
[Musik]
telefonnummer und ein angestellter
nachgegangen geld hinein zu finden und
dann kontaktieren vorbei
[Musik]
aber es waren der rechte die autos der
lage mit kittel zeit nicht
es ist schon so dass das geld auch eine
ungleich verteilt ist
es geht zwar weniger wo sich wirklich
sehr bitter auf dass eine leichte sehr
viele händler gar nichts sagen ach ja
und schön aber das wissen ob das zu
ändern aber ich denke wir mehrere hälfte
und unterstützt das land sich ein pickel
oder automatische als ikone besser
verteilt werden
es ist so dass es noch unterstützen die
entwicklung wenn sie ins land kommt ja
aus thema korruption ist allgegenwärtig
und probiert natürlich möglich finger
davon was mehr problem sind sondern wir
nach aber zuteil ist den machern schuss
leben schwer
[Musik]
erzählt
für dich klaren also weltraum oder auf
also ich wirklich
[Musik]
unterwegs ins armenviertel das sich wie
ein gürtel um die stadt legt die
behörden von ulan bator wollen diese
gebiete neu gestalten
anstelle unzähliger kleine häuschen ohne
wasser und kanalisation sollen hier bald
moderne wohnblocks stehen daniel man sie
hat mit seiner firma den zuschlag
erhalten eines dieser quartiere zu bauen
100 millionen franken projekt doch
zuerst müssen 300 landbesitzer bereit
sein ihr land gegen eine neue
eigentumswohnung ab zu tauschen
sie machen es wichtig und so aber so
dass bestellt weil es ist natürlich so
niedlich finden ein grund und seit du
übrigens die so wird abgerissen
das niveau nicht dafür aber
wahrscheinlich einfach komplett
es wird eine sehr viel versprochen lüth
und vieles wäre nie kalt und einfach
extrem respekt davor dass zu dem schluss
ohne honig darstellen sind sehr hoch
von den 3000 neuen wohnungen werden 300
an die ehemaligen landbesitzer abgegeben
die mehrheit nämlich 2700 wohnungen
sollen vermietet oder verkauft werden
wenn man so will sich nicht als
wohltäter verstanden haben
umgerechnet 10 millionen franken sollen
über die nächsten jahre für ihn und
seine leute herausspringen
voraussetzung dafür ist dass der
aufschwung der stadt anhält und immer
mehr menschen hierher ziehen
[Musik]
kapituliert china werden wiederholt und
ausdauer so zwischen wald und knallt im
business edition müssen zwischen wo
befinden sie sich ja ich liebe es also
still auf dem projekt ist sich ein
ökologisches heißt keine emissionen von
denen viele kohleheizung anschluss aber
kläranlagen und organisation pacers
labour für die nyt oder sind aber
natürlich gehen also es ist so wie in
den nächten oder dem projekt halt
einfach so vor gerade mal zu meiner
familie
zweifellos das analystenteam zu hohe
statische seiten der sound design und
das war's dann muss hole der welt
gemacht
ok ich muss dir vorstellen
die mongolei steht vor der großen
herausforderung zwei welten in einem
land
zu vereinen in der einen welt leben
menschen die nach mitteln suchen um
ihren alltag zu bestreiten
in der anderen welt leben menschen die
für ihre mittel eine verwendung suchen
daniel manser ist überzeugt davon dass
diese zwei unterschiedlichen kulturen
voneinander profitieren können
[Musik]
am letzten tag seines aufenthalts in
ulaanbaatar hat es doch noch geklappt
das geld aus der schweiz ist erfolgreich
in die mongolei transferiert worden
gerade rechtzeitig um den börsengang
doch noch durchzuführen
für mama und seine firma ein wichtiger
moment aber auch für die börse es ist
der erste börsengang hier seit rund zwei
jahren
die händler sind zwar alle schon weg an
diesem freitagnachmittag doch schon am
folgenden montag wird die aktie
gehandelt werden
der handel wird startet das genau die
aktie so entwickelte sich das
unternehmen ist bei der drei ist ist
sehr günstig als potente dh seine psycho
woche noch einen letzten moment noch auf
angriff abgeschlossen hat er steht
derzeit noch nicht fest
[Musik]
andere länder andere sitten sagt der
volksmund
und so ist der abruf für schweizer gaben
ein bisschen ungewöhnlich
[Musik]
doch aller skepsis zum trotz im erfolg
ist der mongole dem appenzeller nach
drei schaafs köpfe machen da keinen
großen unterschied
[Musik]
und den
gestellt
b
als bestes